-Ladies and gentlemen,
it is time
for tonight's show --
"#Hashtags." Here we go.
-♪ #Hashtags ♪
-[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ] Oh.
We do this thing every week
where Tariq and I
send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I went on Twitter.
I sent out the hashtag --
#MarchDadness,
and I asked you guys
to tweet us some funny advice
or weird habits
that your dad has --
some dad advice.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.
So thank you for playing along.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MarchDadness tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one
is from @HylianWxo.
He says...
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can't argue with that.
-Right.
-[ Chuckles ] This one's
from @firstJustinSane.
He says...
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Mouths ] No.
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That must've been the dad
who was drinking all the beers.
-I know. Yeah.
He was drinking all the beers.
He's like, "You drive, kid."
Yeah.
He's not wrong.
No, he's not right either.
I mean, really. Yeah.
-[ Audience laughs ]
-This one's from
@gumgumersonsgum.
He says...
-[ Audience laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Jimmy and Tariq laugh ]
-[ Applause continues ]
-Wow.
"Trade you."
"No, thanks."
-[ Audience laughs ]
-This one's
from @JournalESprott.
He said...
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
What?
-That's wild.
-Yeah.
-So, there's a fire in the house
and he's -- what?
He's gonna take the chainsaw
and cut a hole in the wall?
-In the what?
In the floor?
-That's crazy, man.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Audience laughs ]
-Oh, my goodness.
This one's from BenKeyes.
He says...
-[ Audience laughs ]
[ Rim shot ]
-[ Tariq and Jimmy laughing ]
-Wow.
This one's from @Pamela91998.
She said...
-[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
-Ah. Dad's give, and give,
and give, and you know...
-[ Audience laughs ]
-This last one
is from @UndertheMDsun.
She said...
There you have it.
Those are tonight's
[Chuckles] hashtags.
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to
TonightShow.com/Hashtags.